cette semaine je suis tombé sur une
caméra au bout qu'on vous enfoncent dans
utilisé un petit peu j'avoue c'est quoi
pas de moteur et rien du tout c'est
il ya encore pas mal de trucs à régler
vidéo particulièrement étrange est-ce
petit robot c'est pas un robot au sens
juste une petite boule puante comment
cette histoire de petit caca venom qui
un orifice naturel pour voir ce qui se
avant d'imaginer pouvoir l'utiliser pour
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
où on imagine quand on ne m'entend
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
elle fait pour bouger je viens de vous
se déplacent tout seul est-ce que j'ai
que vous avez déjà vu un étron qui se
passe dedans bon ça a quand même un
smolar en général il n'y a pas de
tous ceux dont je vous ai parlé la
le dire en fait c'est un petit robot
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
définitivement sombrer dans la folie
certain diamètre donc ça peut pas aller
poudre à déterminer comment on va suivre
déplace
mécanisme n'y a pas de moteur à
magnétique accords nous donc pour le
autres mettez vous bien et surtout
fiscale au point de voir des petites
partout et en plus d'être limitée par le
non je ne parle pas de la campagne
l'intérieur et rien du tout ce truc
sa progression à l'intérieur du corps
portez vous
crottes prendre vie comme ça devant mes
diamètre on est aussi limitée par la
humain parce qu'il a pas de caméra et on
c'est un robot magnétique accord mot
présidentielle
manipuler pour le télécommande et si
yeux mais pas du tout je vous rassure
longueur du petit tuyau et vu que notre
va pas naviguer à la bob faudra sans
alors un étron qui se déplacent
vous voulez on utilise des éléments en
évidemment c'est une nouvelle fois l'ami
magnétique oui parce que c'est grâce à
petit machin là il n'a pas de fil à la
doute y ait un contrôle visuel en temps
pierre gerner je vous remets le lien
ça qu'ils se déplacent il a plein de
réel avec une radio par exemple et tout
gros je sais pas si vous avez déjà fait
non plus moi je vous parle d'un tout
vers son blog dans la description qui
patte lui il peut aller plus loin alors
ça c'est un peu comme si vous faisiez
particularités que je vais vous
ça sous le contrôle d'un chirurgien ou
expliquer après mais une de ses
m'a envoyé une vidéo la fameuse vidéo
bouger un objet posé sur une table en
petit truc qui se déplacent tout seul
imaginer quelque chose à mi chemin entre
à quel point il peut aller plus loin eh
principales sait qu'il est capable de se
d'un médecin on va pas s'amuser à faire
intrigante dont je vous parlais tout à
un petit caca et un symbiote vous savez
déplaçant un aimant en dessous balas et
glisser un petit peu partout y compris
ça à l'apéro à la maison avec les potes
ben j'ai posé la question à mon camarade
l'heure et que voilà
même principe sauf que l'objet il est ni
dans des petits espaces très étroit très
et puis il faut être sûr qu'on va pas en
comme venom mais un mini venom vous en
chercheurs et selon lui vu qu'un champ
perdre un bout en route alors là dessus
complètement solide ni complètement
sinueux vu qu'il est télécommandé de
magnétique ça peut traverser tout le
liquide un petit peu comme ce que vous
avez peut-être déjà vu il y en a plein
a priori sont confiants parce que le
corps de bout en bout sans problème dans
sur tik tok par exemple sauf que celui
voyez là et sauf que l'objet vous avez
l'extérieur donc on va voir l'envoyer en
robot a la capacité de se réparer tout
compris c'est pas sur une table qui se
mission dans des endroits inaccessibles
dont je vous parle il va vraiment
l'absolu le petit machin il peut aller
seul en allant récupérer les boues qui
déplace et là en l'occurrence qu'on
pour l'homme et pour des robots en
pouvoir se glisser à l'intérieur de vous
aussi loin qu'on veut par exemple il m'a
utilise ce n'est pas un petit aimant
ce que vous venez de voir c'est une
l'aurait perdu mais on est d'accord que
matière solide et comme parmi les
pour vous soigner attention tout bien
tout péter et sous une table ses deux
dit et je le cite nous nous attendons à
c'est mieux d'être sûr quand même
espèce de petit robot tout mou dont
bras robotisés sur lesquels on a fixé
tout honneur et encore je dis ça mais on
chercheurs il ya notamment les angles
d'autant qu'on sait pas trop ce que ça
pouvoir actionner à distance le robot
l'une des missions s'arrête de nous
donnerait s'il y avait un petit bout de
en est pas encore là parce que la
des aimants sphérique ça permet d'avoir
qui fait aussi partie du département de
technologie en est encore au tout début
stein qui reste est squatté à
soigner ont soigné de l'intérieur donc
visqueux dans toute la région du tractus
chirurgie et de la faculté de médecine
l'intérieur de nous et puis on sait que
encore un petit peu le temps de voir
des mouvements précis de faire réagir
il a été développé par une équipe de
de l'université chinoise de hong kong
le borax c'est déconseillé pour les
les particules magnétiques qui sont à
gastro intestinal
venir bon mais je vous vois vous en
chercheurs et d'ingénieurs chinois qui
patiente et là qu'est ce que c'est que
alors je traduis pour ce combat fait
femmes enceintes par exemple bref tout
vous imaginez à quoi il a foncé et
l'intérieur du petit robot ans line et
ces balivernes qu'est ce que je vous
vient de publier les résultats de ses
ça ça ce tchèque et puis ya des cas où
chercheurs lv2 dans l'absolu on peut
raconte depuis tout à l'heure de quoi je
de le manipuler à distance pour le
qu'est ce que c'est que cette matière si
recherches et notamment cette fameuse
ce sera probablement pas possible
suis en train de parler eh ben on va
imaginer introduire le bbv nomme par
tu es donc non c'est évidemment
d'utiliser cette technique notamment à
vidéo c'est surprenant un mois quand
déformer et lui faire faire ce qu'on
voir ça tout de suite bon ok j'ai
absolument pas de la matière fécale
veut mais pourquoi giral m venom alors
l'anus lui faire parcourir les mètres de
j'ai vu la vidéo il ya plein de
cause du champ magnétique chez les gens
grandissez un peu en fait c'est ce qu'on
questions qui me sont venues d'un coup
qui ont des implants métalliques ça
j'en remets pension bois mais qu'est ce
canalisations qu'on a là dedans et le
appelle un fluide non newtonien c'est
risquerait de les déplacer par exemple
déjà noter que notre corps il a
que c'est que ce truc ou qu'est ce que
faire ressortir par la bouche ou dans
plus classe mais c'est moins facile à
et puis chez les gens qui ont un
plusieurs portes d'entrée donc on n'est
c'est que ces pierres ou encore mais
dire ça veut dire que c'est un truc
pacemaker là ça risquerait carrément de
pas obligé de on va y revenir ensuite
visqueux qui change de textures en
l'autre sens c'est chacun son goût donc
les empêcher de marcher correctement
comment ça marche ce truc et puis
fonction des conditions auxquelles il
notre petit flotteur marron là il a
d'ailleurs on sait que pour les gens qui
surtout mais pourquoi j'irais me mettre
est soumis il devient plus ou moins
bref ce tir au but quand ils pourraient
sont dans les cas que j'ai incité ça
plein de talent mais ses deux principaux
aller récupérer des corps étrangers
liquide selon les cas de figure pour
venom dans le cas venom dans le hard a
peut être compliqué passé une irm par
points forts c'est qui peut se glisser
coincés dans notre corps ou au pire s'il
être plus précis c'est un hydrogène qui
été jusqu'à la dernière minute le titre
exemple parce que ça utilise une
un petit peu n'importe où comme on l'a
de travail de cette vidéo et puis
est composé notamment d'alcool produits
technologie à résonance magnétique aussi
n'arrive pas à les sortir parce qu'ils
déjà dit mais aussi qui peut attraper
finalement j'ai opté pour quelque chose
vinyliques donc un polymère et de
pour les choses sont un petit peu en
sont trop coincé il pourrait sécuriser
de plus informatif beaucoup de questions
train de changer là dessus et que tu as
des trucs oui il peut attraper des trucs
cristaux d'un minerai qui s'appelle du
la zone et là par exemple ils ont fait
on sait pas complètement un sujet mais
qui ne pouvait décemment pas rester sans
soit il utilise sa technique de pac man
borax ça a l'air compliqué comme ça mais
une expérience en laissant une pile sur
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans la
réponse donc j'ai cherché parmi les
technologie là qui nous intéresse
en fait c'est ni plus ni moins que la
en gros il avale un truc et
auteurs de l'étude et j'ai fini par
une matière qui est à peu près
l'intensité magnétique et ready fois
recette du slide le jouet du slime
l'équivalent de ce qui tapissent notre
trouver le mail de l'un d'entre eux le
moins forte qu avec unia donc faut voir
soit si la forme de l'objet à attraper
auquel on ajoute des particules
paroi intestinale au bout de dix minutes
professeur li yang de l'université
magnétiques ce qui en plus de lui donner
la pile elle avait abîmé la muqueuse
bon ben vous avez compris qu'il reste du
permet pas de laval est complètement pas
chinoise de hong kong je lui a envoyé un
cette coloration sur laquelle on va pas
puis ils ont essayé avec une pile
temps et du chemin à parcourir avant que
de problème il a une autre technique hop
revenir lui permettre d'être contrôlés à
enveloppé dans le petit robot ans times
petit message sympa
bébé venom prennent possession de nos
il se fait pousser un bras et bien sûr
et devinez quoi
et au bout de dix minutes
distance
orifices naturels comme à chaque fois
mais comment ça marche et oui il n'y a
apparemment la paroisse n'avaient pas
s'il ya plusieurs trucs à attraper pas
qu'un nouveau traitement ou une nouvelle
donc voilà j'en sais un peu plus et je
souffert ce qui pourrait permettre de
de problème il se fait pousser plusieurs
technique et développer il faut passer
limiter la casse en attendant de venir
mois du coup première utilisation aller
vais vous raconter ça je pense que le
récupérer un objet contrer autre
par tout un tas d'étape pour s'assurer
chercher un corps étrangers coincés dans
plus simple pour vous raconter tout ça
que tout est ok avant même de pouvoir
utilisation possible le transport de
c'est de reprendre les fameuses
imaginer commencer les tests sur les
un petit trou ou un petit tuyau sans
questions qui se sont imposés à moi
médicaments allait déposer un traitement
quand j'ai vu la vidéo pour la première
avoir besoin de tout bousiller sa marche
humains et c'est très bien comme ça on
pile à l'endroit dont le corps on a
fois mais qu'on s'emploie mais qu'est ce
pour la plomberie mais vous avez compris
n'est jamais trop prudent on sait pas ce
que c'est que ce truc alors déjà ce
besoin d'ailleurs le professeur homme il
ça marche aussi pour notre fils naturel
qui peut se passer voilà dtc c'est fini
a aussi participé au développement de
on peut aller chercher des trucs dedans
petits robots en hydrogène contrôler
sans avoir besoin d'ouvrir
chirurgicalement le professeur yang m'a
magnetic man en forme de poisson qu'ils
confirmé qu'on pouvait très bien
sont capables d'aller déposer des
imaginer envoyé le petit bestiaux
molécules de chimiothérapie directement
chercher les tripes coincé dans une
au contact des tumeurs et il ya aussi
oreille dans le nez dans la gorge dans
d'autres types de robots de différentes
l'oesophage dans la trachée dans
formes et de différentes compositions
l'urètre ou dans le côlon et si vous
qui sont à l'étude notamment dans le
voyez pas pourquoi on aurait besoin de
domaine de ce qu'on appelle la robotique
faire ça je vous renvoie à mes deux
douce ou molle des nanorobots et cetera
vidéos récentes sur le sujet et
l'avantagé c'est qu'ils pourraient avoir
accès à des endroits où même un
bref vous reparler de ça en ce jour si
endoscope a du mal à aller s'avère un
ça vous intéresse en attendant
endoscope c'est un petit tuyau avec une
poursuit-il nous concerne aujourd'hui je
voulais on en est encore au tout début
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]